ce projet de long métrage c'est avant
tout une aventure humaine un rêve de
gosse
parce que lorsque j'avais 10 ans j'ai
découvert le film jurassic park de
steven spielberg et ce jour là j'ai j'ai
compris qu'en fait ce qui m'intéressait
finalement plus que tout c'était de
raconter à mon tour des histoires et
faire rêver les gens le temps d'un film
fini le rêve de gosse alex est
aujourd'hui un cinéaste accompli quatre
années de réflexion et 7 versions de
scénario plus tard le tournage commence
action en réalité j'avais un peu
abandonné l'espoir on va dire de pouvoir
faire ce premier long métrage en mai 30
ou 35 ans parce que c'est un peu
pratique la moyenne d'âge d'un jeune
réalisateur français pour un premier
long et
et en fait en janvier dernier avec
l'équipe des loups blancs qui donc avec
qui j'ai évolué au quotidien m'ont dit
que c'était aussi voile alors leur
objectif de x et hey c'était quelque
chose qu'il fallait pas lâcher et donc
du coup
on s'est penché sur le projet et ont
ainsi mis à fond donc là on est neuf
mois plus tard et c'est le début du
tournage
après avoir réalisé une centaine de
courts métrages et remporter une
trentaine de prix dont quelques-uns à
hollywood
alex passe aux choses sérieuses mais
toujours avec le sourire
c'est l'histoire d'une relation entre
une mère et sa fille y est
et malheureusement j'ai pas pouvoir en
dire trop parce que c'est un thriller
psychologique qui invite le spectateur
en fait à résoudre une énigme tourangeau
de naissance et de coeur il a voulu
réaliser ce long métrage dans sa région
mais il n'est pas seul dans cette
aventure
une dizaine de personnes l'accompagnent
le fait qu' un jeune ça veut pas dire
qu'il n'a pas d'expérience de joie parce
que alex il a quand même un cv assez
remplie et puis c'est sa passion qui
compte c'est pas non c'est pas une
question d'âge la pression est forte et
le timing serré
l'objectif est de terminer le tournage
d'ici quelques semaines pour une sortie
dès le début de l'année 2016